unter adler der einzige echte bauexperte
in dem laden nicht raus sind super
signal
wo doch heute im kanzleramt der große
wohn gipfel stand findet wohnungsnot das
ist so ein echtes problem was eine echte
regierung echt mal angreifen könnte
statt über maßen zu reden gerade jetzt
zum semesterbeginn wo es für viele arme
studenten heißt mut zur brücke ja ja es
wäre kein witz es fehlen fast zwei
millionen wohnungen in deutschland die
sich normalverdiener noch leisten können
beim gipfel heute waren übrigens
immobilienverbände und hausbesitzer
lobby technisch deutlich in der überzahl
aber ich sage die mieter waren auch
irgendwie vertreten also zunächst kann
ich bestätigen dass wir beim hohen
gipfel dabei sind unser präsident darf
glaube ich 90 sekunden sprechen so ist
es mir mitgeteilt worden das ist
natürlich eine menge 60 nur hoch sind
nur 60 sekunden
ok dann habe ich mich vertan da muss
auch schneller sprechen
die groko hat sich ja tatsächlich müssen
wir zugeben einige gut gemeinte
maßnahmen gegen wohnungsnot ausgedacht
aber die reichen nicht ansatzweise vor
allem wenn man bedenkt was vor allem in
deutschen großstädten gerade los eine
wohnung im zentrum träumen weiter
in berlin wurde unlängst ein zelt auf
einem balkon angeboten zur miete 260
euro warum
willkommen im hotel kempinski bei der
damen und herren ja das liegt aber voll
im trend
hier an aus münchen ein schlafsack in
der gefriertruhe 350 euro kalt
das kriegen sie vermietet ich schwör's
ihnen
ich hab's versucht eine million
haushalte eine million haushalte in
deutschland geben inzwischen mehr als 50
prozent ihres einkommens für miete aus
arm durch wohnen ist die soziale frage
unserer zeit echt hart für
wohnungssuchende sagen wir mal aber für
die immobilienbranche ist ein tränchen
alleine das unternehmen wo nokia hat im
letzten jahr knapp eine milliarde gewinn
gemacht knapp eine milliarde wir wissen
solche firmen kaufen massenhaft
wohnungen auf modernisieren irgendwas
und dann steigt die miete aber wie im
fall dieser mieterin um 74 prozent
aber man hat sie recht charmant
mitgeteilt alle bewohner haben ein
schreiben von der hausverwaltung
bekommen mit folgendem hinweis leben
heißt veränderung
wow
auf welcher arschloch akademie lernt man
solche sätze unglaublich elf prozent der
modernisierungskosten dürfen auf den
mieter ganz legal pro jahr umgelegt
werden demnächst nur noch 8 und auch
eine gute nachricht seit dieser woche
können sie das so genannte baukindergeld
beantragen wissens in 1200 euro pro kind
und jahr motto knattern ich ins
eigenheim
warum nicht hier wohnen nicht ja den ist
der server zusammengebrochen diese woche
wirklich ist so ein schöner bonus für
leute die sich im hausbau leisten können
die spd schlägt vor mieten für fünf
jahre nur noch wenn die inflation
steigen zu lassen aber dass wir die
union nicht und wir alle wissen wie der
streit ausgeht
ja die kommunen das ist fakt die
kommunen müssten viel mehr grundstücke
aufkaufen aber wie geht das bei den
preisen in berlin sind die bodenpreise
in den letzten fünf jahren auch dank
spekulanten um 345 prozent gestiegen ja
das neue zauberwort heißt deshalb
verdichtung unsere städte sollen
unbedingt verdichtet werden sebastian
pufpaff ist diplom verdichter bei der
stadt köln verpufft
oktober
es muss verdichtet werden was heißt das
genau ja unser slogan herr welke lautet
köln voll ist noch nicht dicht genug
versteht ja gut also wenn man sich die
stadt von oben anschaut gibt es immer
noch massenhaft unbebaute flächen ihr
kummer flächen wo absolut kein haus
drauf steht das grüne ich habe extra mal
gegoogelt ist so genannter rasen sagen
wer braucht denn den dreck der wohl kein
mensch oder hier kann man da dessen
friedhof lachen
der wohn zwar welche aber die zahlen
seit jahren weit unter mietspiegel und
ich sage warum nicht auf den klaus noch
ein haus oder oder hier wird auch auf
der oberkante noch moni verdichtung
verdichtung
minute zeit ab
[Musik]
ich mag diese ehrliche diese ehrliche
emotionen also verdichtung verdichtung
heißt den vorhandenen raum maximal mit
beton zu ballern ja ich habe hier mal
ein mietshaus modell
guck mal hier mit innenhof so und jetzt
mach dich mal frei unter der von tabelle
also warum nicht ein haus bauen das
genau in diesen in nur ein paar mal hier
da passt noch immer eine wurst zwischen
mit solider aber dann hat auch keiner in
dem ding mehr licht okay das können sie
jetzt als ostwestfale nicht wissen
aber bei uns in köln haben wir so
genannten strom ja und lampen
das hat sich eigentlich bewährt aber
frauen
aber mal ernsthaft mein kleiner
schmetterling
ich habe einen konkreten hilfsplan für
den wohnungsmangel in deutschen
großstädten in einer sehr aufwendigen
animationen zusammengefasst na ja
wunderbar wunderbar ist nur umsonst app
zwei verlängerungen wir brauchen keine
hauses dann die termiten
die wohnung ist ein kleiner werden dann
werden die menschen auch wieder kleiner
ja das ist wie zu kleine schuhe da
gewöhnt sich der fuß dran
und warum haben gebäude hier immer nur
eine funktion
das ist eine schule dass es ein museum
das es das jobcenter und das ist eine
wohnung und das eine tankstelle aber
dass man halt vielleicht überlegt dass
eine wohnung auch eine ausstellung sein
kann wie ein museum oder das eine schule
gleichzeitig aber auch eine wohnung sein
kann ja dass eine wohnung auch mal eine
tankstelle sein ja wort kommen ja zack
wird weniger geraucht und wenn doch hast
du wieder baugrundstück
ja
wer sagt denn eine toilette kann niemals
eine küche sein
wo steht das woher welt ich weiß es
nicht ich finde das ja auch richtig mit
dem verdichten und tiny hauses aber
können wir nicht einmal machen wie die
stadt wien die hälfte der wiener wohnt
relativ günstig weil die stadt wien mit
steuergeld massenhaft wohnung kaufen
das nein das können sie gar nicht
vergleichen das sind österreicher ja die
hälfte erhält von den wohnungen sonst im
keller
ich spreche gerne vom sogenannten fritz
faktor also mit österreichern können wir
uns nicht messen ein neues wiener
stadtviertel entsteht
und da staunt der deutsche spd vize
thorsten schäfer gümbel von ersten
plänen ist zu den ersten 3000 wohnungen
hat es gerade mal sieben jahre gedauert
dann in deutsche baubehörde noch nicht
meinen briefkasten geleert kommt lesen
sie welches bauprojekt bei uns als
einziges in sieben jahren durchgezogen
wurde
nein dieses vogelhäuschen vor dem
kanzleramt wird jetzt aber leider wieder
abgerissen gegen brandschutz natürlich
sebastian bach
[Applaus]
[Musik]